my next guest moved from the nfc west to
the nfc south where he's uh
he's having a great time
because he is the defending head coach
uh in this year's competition to try and
repeat as super bowl champions and in
six days he and his buccaneers will kick
off the season raise a banner and turn
the page with the dallas cowboys in the
house he is bruce arians how are you
coach
rich i'm doing great buddy how you doing
i'm doing better for talking to you when
i hear your voice i think football and
we're back we're back
we're back baby i'm so excited about
that so
um first things first uh
what what is it like in your locker room
right now how much you talking about
last year and paige turning right now
bruce aaron's
you know we we kind of put that to bed
rich in may
at the mandatory mini camp and our guys
have been
you know we're so fortunate our defense
and our offense are really good so they
get after each other so much in practice
you can't stand back and relax and
if you do you get exposed real quick so
i've had to say very very little about
it uh obviously they'll drop a banner
but uh last year's over it's a whole new
season it's also got to be good that
you've got a quarterback that's been
there and done that oh six times
having to defend something like that how
much has brady been i guess preaching
the same gospel as you on page turning
bruce arians yeah he's been fantastic
rich i mean he and gronk jpp i mean
they've all been there we've got about
six or seven coaches they're all one
super bowl so it's
you know just keep beating everybody in
the head and uh
you know
again our guys when they turn on film
they know what work looks like and we
have not had any problem with with the
work
and um
what's brady been like
just give me a good example of what he's
been like uh right now compared to the
year before and and what you need in
terms of a quarterback to lead the
charge for a title defense bruce aaron's
yeah it's i mean it's light years
difference i mean this year he knows
what the words mean
when he's calling plays and last year he
at this time he barely did and uh so
yeah i mean
he's so much more comfortable in his
skin and and everything that we're doing
you know
coming to work the facility everything
that that he did for 20 years was
different last year this year it's the
same old stuff so he can really
i never knew tom was such a great guy
with young players but he's a fantastic
guy with young players
how so can you give me an example please
bruce sirens yeah i mean
veteran players are young players you
know coaches hey you know you're not
pumping your arms coming out of your
brakes man your arms are going dead as
soon as your head turns around and they
say oh yeah okay it's cool
and then tom goes hey man i need your
arms to pump and you're coming out of
that break because i'm gonna throw the
ball out in front of you and
okay tom i'll do it next thing they do
it i was like i've been trying to tell
you to do that [ __ ] for a month now
so now it's just like hey tom can you
tell this guy to go do this for me
and it gets done
and you're like come on i'm the coach
like i've been you know
i used to be hanging around bear bryant
for crying out loud you ever see
they don't even these guys don't even
know who that is i bet
i bet oh my gosh uh i mean but a little
bit more on brady uh i've got bruce
erin's here on the rich eisen show
because you were on i'm i'm trying to
think it was around
just after thanksgiving on this on this
show
um
you were on just after thanksgiving and
i asked you when you think brady was
gonna have the full grasp of the offense
and you said maybe next spring
and then you won the super bowl anyway
but that does like now
now we're in the next summer we're in
the next fall and how does brady having
a year under his belt offensively with
all of that knowledge neck up chest with
that heart beating inside how that will
actually manifest itself do you think in
the 2021 season
yeah i mean it's been great i mean it's
great and you know he he hates losing so
he had a two-minute drill about three
weeks ago
and the defense stopped him on fourth
and five and you know he threw his
helmet he kicked the ball across the
other field he was so pissed
and uh
so that fire burns man i mean i've never
seen it
it doesn't burn that hot in some young
players yet alone the guy's 44 but
he's been he's been amazing and uh every
single day just just what he brings to
practice his competitive fire like i
said i never i never have to say hey you
guys ain't practicing hard enough
offensively especially with him but
defensively with which levante and shaq
and jp and sue and those guys they they
know they stay after it and defensively
how is your unit improved do you think
from last year's remarkable run in which
they they anchored quite a bit obviously
we do focus on the offensive side of the
ball but let's be let's let's call it
brass tacks i mean in many different
ways your defense caused kansas city to
realign their entire offensive line
based on what happened on your field on
that february night when you pick
confetti out of the ground so what about
the defense do you think is better this
year bruce yeah i think that i think our
young secondary now kind of understands
why they do things they they knew what
to do but to know why you're doing it
and what you're trying to beat the route
concepts and and all the things that
todd has taught those guys
um adding some younger players uh to the
mix and uh it's been fun to watch their
growth like i said
um we've got great battles when we go
against ourselves in training camp on
offense versus defense so
just just the continued growth of those
guys
um
adding joe tryon and a couple of young
guys it's it's fun to watch bruce arians
here in advance of thursday night
kickoff against the dallas cowboys that
you can hear
right here on westwood one radio the
cowboys sir what challenges do they
present to you
on the thursday night kickoff
a bunch when you go back and look at
when they were healthy how good they
were offensively that you know averaging
over 400 yards a game and you know i
love dak prescott i think he's one of
the
classiest dudes and one of the best
leaders in this game
zeke's healthy their offensive line to
selfie i mean they got decimated last
year then defensively
um they're playing a defense that fits
their personnel
dan quinn's a great coach and uh and
they'll be sound and uh
you know we know what kind of challenge
we're up for yeah i mean
let's talk about the dan quinn of it all
because that has been a large part of
the conversation how dallas and their
defensive woes from last year
automatically will be better just
because of him and what he's bringing
and the scheme he's bringing might be a
better scheme fit for their players are
you seeing that on film so far
oh definitely i think having been a 4-3
team and then switching to 3-4
the personnel matches up what they're
trying to do now and
their young secondary got
they got a lot of experience last year
so
yeah i mean like a ton of speed on
defense so the young linebacker looks
fantastic and
so yeah they
again they're healthy on defense too but
uh i think there's no doubt what what
dandy does defensively it fits their
their personnel bruce arians here on the
rich eisen show speaking of health 100
vaccination rate congratulations coach
on that i appreciate yeah it was the
goal of our whole organization and we've
got the entire organization
uh vaccinated and healthy so what was
the message that you delivered um to
players who were on the fence needed
more information or potentially
steadfast against the idea uh and then
eventually took the jab what was your
process in that bruce arians it
basically was it was a personal decision
but to get as much information and
knowledge uh
don't read on the internet i mean get
real facts
um and uh
whether we had i never had to bring in a
specialist we've got great doctors here
uh who who basically read you know gave
them the facts
uh
we live in an area in florida where it's
rampant
and uh so
you're gonna get less sick if you're
vaccinated and we had we've had a number
of
vaccinated people test positive through
training camp
but only have the sniffles i know you
got it worse but
nobody got anything serious whatsoever
but just just continue to educate
no i exactly i got it and it lasted four
days it was dreadful but the fear of it
could go in any direction was just as
bad as the actual symptoms i was feeling
and uh me i i was glad that i was
quarantined i was glad that i was away
from others and certainly if i was
around somebody as old as tom moore i
would make sure i was
um
you know protecting myself and and
others around right i mean like that
that would be my general sense of it to
be very honest
coach you know and and again i think i
think there's so much respect in our
building for each other
um
that no one wanted to bring it in the
building you know i'm i'll be 69 times
gonna be 83 and
um
this it's gonna damage us tremendously
if we get it so
guys were great last year our team was i
mean it was one of the reasons we went
all the way is we didn't have to fight
it very hard the guys just bought in
and they know where they live so
um
you know
you test positive now you're missing
games again even though you're
vaccinated which i'm not a fan of but uh
so
just still gotta be very smart about it
bruce erin's here on the rich eisen show
all right uh if you'll indulge if you'll
indulge because i know you've take page
turn you said you turned the page in may
but just
what will it mean to you when you see a
banner raised in your building that you
won in a game in your building
right that you protected your house in
the ultimate game against a team that
had one of the
you know most dangerous quarterbacks uh
that we've seen in quite some time you
vanquished all of it what will it mean
to you
before you obviously put your sights on
the dallas cowboys on thursday night to
watch that banner go up do you think
bruce yeah i'm sure i'm sure
i'm sure i'll get chills rich but i've
been kind of over it and my ring
ceremony was really late and it was like
okay you finally got the rings
everything let's get to the next year
i've been pushing next year for a long
time so uh it it'll it'll hit i think
everybody that was part of that team
and and my message is everybody's
standing on the sideline that's not you
you didn't win that banner
all right that was last year's team they
won that banner god bless them let's see
what you guys got tonight what is it
that's not you that's the phrase that
you're using right yeah that's you
didn't win you didn't win that banner
that's that's last year's bunch
this is now this year and by the way so
you call that a ring i call that an
igloo
really
i've never seen anything like that
special it's pretty special honestly
it's it's like circ you know rings are
usually like oval right like a walnut
shape that thing was a circle right or
it is
yeah it's it's
darcy gla cassowitz
glazier did uh glazer cassie which i'm
sorry did an unbelievable job darcy's
the best and and just putting that thing
together and the thought that went into
it and uh
all the intricacies of what what the
ring is designed for us yeah i've worn
it twice and it's it's special holy crap
i'm looking at a photograph it opens up
the top opens up it really does
yeah in the state and it has the outline
of the stadium with history because for
the first team they ever went at home
yeah wow and all the all those little
319 diamonds scores 31 and 9 up not all
everything on that ring has some kind of
meaning so what are the two times the
night you got it and what's the second
when was the second time you wore it
to the white house what not to the white
excuse me we got it after the white
house where did i wear it yeah
um
okay i was trying to impress somebody
[Laughter]
it wasn't the white house you didn't
wear it because that would have set off
security
no no i
didn't get until the next day we got the
went to the white house before we got
the ring okay and uh i'm trying to write
it out where
it's all good i can't remember now
oh
i don't know
okay you just put that thing away then
you'll just wear it another time just
got to win another one i can't even
imagine how big that would be my gosh
oh it can't be any bigger okay well look
bruce thanks for the call uh your family
everything's good life's good your
everybody's healthy and your family
everything's great yeah everything's
fantastic and they're hopefully
everybody's great out there and how's
your foundation let me ask you about
that before we go tell me about the
foundation wrong yeah going strong we
had you know unbelievable event
in the spring and um
broke all our records so we're we're
trying to figure out what we can do next
and uh
you know my son's doing a great job
running the foundation fantastic
so there yeah we're
yes it's uh it's the arians
aryansfamilyfoundation.com beautiful at
aryansff on twitter and instagram i
would be remiss if i didn't ask you uh
this this uh video and quote from your
from your quarterback
uh tom brady has gone viral uh where he
was talking i guess it was an in-house
conversation with gran i thought i saw
gronk there and mike evans i don't know
if you've seen this sound bite where
brady's saying that the uh league
throwing flags on defensive players for
hitting an offensive player that is
so-called um
uh uh uh defenseless
that it's sometimes on the offensive
player and the quarterback and the and
the and the wide receivers probably it's
their fault for running into the defense
and not knowing it
uh and making themselves defenseless and
quarterback putting a ball in a certain
spot and that offensive player should
have a certain responsibility on keeping
offensive players healthy don't leave it
to the defense did you see that and if
not what do you think of that yeah
we we actually had a long conversation
uh
we were we were on a second hole the
other day playing golf and it rained on
us so okay i had a nice conversation
about the rule changes and how
you know i'm like yeah you throw the
ball into the flat and cover two and the
guy gets blown up the quarterbacks
should get the penalty nothing not the
guy hitting him right and uh so it's
like
you know they make the onus on the
defense so so hard anymore and and the
strike strike zone you can only bend
guys can only bend so far
the guy your tackling's bending down and
you've been down your heads are gonna
hit you got shoulder pads on you know
what i mean
uh so yeah i'm not all for all the rules
i'm for player safety believe me sure
but uh
some of some of them are getting out of
hand well sure like and so so brady's
statement or that comment might have
been asked a direct question i don't
know what the question was was kind of
borne out it was honest is on his mind
because the two of you had a
conversation during a rain delay in golf
that's what you're saying very summer
okay all right i love the origin stories
about that sort of stuff coach thanks
for the call best your family let's do
this uh during the season and have a
great kick off against the dallas
cowboys the whole country's watching as
you know
you bet thanks richard you got that's
bruce erin's always great to talk to
bruce arians here on the rich eyes and
show the
hc of
the tv
the tampa bay buccaneers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here